welcome to this video playing in faro
from from maybe it's from the North
swietenia not the harbor islands this
will be Denmark okay so from Sweden and
let's see classically French and
weekends thus pilots let's see what line
is playing a six it's one of the main
lines nowadays yeah I don't know exactly
how it is played hey this is the this is
down I think the traditional line with
Queen f2 at least this was the line when
the main line when when I um when I
study dust it for the black side check
yes this is this isn't too great to be
honest because some now black runs into
risk to get the classic log bed and game
here with the night against bishop it's
at least a very passive position okay so
mmm if I go King III kicking if it takes
Knight a to literally on or maybe maybe
yeah okay we can I can also play like
that 93 Jays King III night c 2 I can
just play rock somewhere doesn't matter
okay so let's let's check this before
hmm yeah III should be good yeah I don't
really understand why is playing this so
quickly is it that easy I don't I don't
really think so now is some is getting
another porno light squares okay just
here getting the rooks off this end game
okay okay this is maybe an idea just not
exchange the looks but
okay let's clarify the structure i can
always go ok one rock c7 of course was a
more direct way to play but i don't i
don't turn and now he's are allowing the
exchange strangely enough ok so 95 yeah
95 it's just it's just a flat-out win
actually I'm threatening to take this
seven take be five and if he goes Bishop
be aight i take and i know i will the be
problem you don't see how he protects it
I just blew it forward and take it
ok so just deform the Sun better move
along before i submit good so is it is
it the easiest if i go king before and
mighty hiking before cannot be bad just
go here and then try to improve write a
five Kings e7 it's not so clear what the
night is doing 185 so it's a probably
better to try to use this piece to
generate more play here on the King side
maybe night to be form not to be foil
lighter before us a good idea
it's really not that sorry not that easy
mm-hmm not really finding the right
approach him maybe I need to regroup
this piece to 2d three or something and
then I need to make some progress here
on the on the kingside the night would
be nice on III actually to support f5
yeah I know we're getting somewhere
13 g5 with the breakthrough
I couldn't he couldn't relax resign he
couldn't really prevent it yeah I needed
to reroute the pieces and then play on
the kingside there was no real maybe no
real way to to just win it on the
queenside but just this is so this is
the way to go yeah he was very young um
cooperative in a way just going into the
structure here take on d3 and exchange
points is really a very risky decision
because you really are close to to to
this night manned game all the time you
know I'm not sure about 85 I mean we we
then got the Sun he only got this
weakness unknown on before yeah I could
have taken on a five but I didn't want
to I just wanted to have this nice
structure yeah idea i think 95 just
flat-out wins it just went SAP on he
could could play here but then i can i
can just take it and and win that we
will move on I think v5 king before
takes it no way to prevent that yeah
well so was it was just a bad end game
so the kind of endgame the French player
should avoid like the plague it's very
often just flat-out lost and here maybe
I could have taken and even 11 quicker
alright thanks for watching